I am extremely proud to say that we are
turning the tide on batteries
thanks to enormous effort by seven
member states industry and the European
Commission we see a first truly pan
European consortium emerging with highly
innovative project in all segments of
the value chain in all 17 key industrial
players and over 70 external partners
our industry is in the lead the European
Commission and the Member States are in
full support and I want to applaud the
unprecedented coordination work by
France and namely by economic minister
Bruno lemare with his counterparts in
other EU countries and I also appreciate
the excellent work done by Commission's
vice president Marc addressed a girl who
had ensured that this important
industrial project can go ahead without
distorting competition so what can we
expect on the ground we are helping pave
the way to a pilot plant in new
l-akhirin region of France and
eventually to to [ __ ] factories for the
battery cells production one in France
and one in Germany the completion of the
overall project is planned for 2030 one
however this is still the beginning of
our European story in the area of
batteries we are working hard when it
comes to a second battery consortium
thanks to enormous coordination efforts
but Germany and economic Minister Peter
admire the European battery Alliance
will continue to help so that we secure
the long-term future of Europe's
alternative and renewables industries we
only have a small window of two to three
years to establish genuine European
leadership and mass production in this
strategic technology at the end we want
to capture a great part of European
market but at the same time
substantially expand our exporting and
investment capacity globally the
European battery Alliance is a blueprint
for 21st century proof industrial policy
with this recipe I have no doubt we
and do it